The former president.
He is
once again
raising the specter of violence
and inciting his followers.
And he didn't even lose an election
this time.
No, this time he was up at 1 a.m.
last night attacking a local prosecutor,
calling him a degenerate
and figuratively
unleashing the dogs of war
on the entire country.
What does that suggest about
how he sees this situation
and the larger legal storm he's facing?
Some clues to be found
in what he posted at one
this morning on his social network
about Manhattan D.A. Alvin Bragg.
And potential charges
in the Stormy Daniels
hush money investigation.
He asks how it can happen. One quote.
It is known by all that
no crime has been committed
and also known the potential death
and destruction
and such a false charge
could be catastrophic for our country.
Why and who would do such a thing?
His conclusion,
only a degenerate psychopath
who truly hates the USA.
Now, this comes a day
after he called Bragg
an animal
and posted this photo of himself
getting ready to swing a baseball bat
next to a photo of Bragg.
And just today, brags
office received a package
containing white powder
and a threatening note.
Now, the powder thankfully,
proved to be harmless,
certainly less toxic
than some on both sides of the aisle
say the rhetoric is,
well, twice impeached.
Former president's rhetoric is reckless,
reprehensible and irresponsible.
It's dangerous.
And if he keeps it up,
he's going to get someone killed.
And that's House
Minority Leader Hakeem Jeffries.
His Republican counterpart,
Steve Scalise,
said there is no place in America
for political violence of any kind.
But he also echoed the former
president accusing
Bragg of carrying out,
in his words, a political vendetta.
And Jim Jordan, who chairs the House
Judiciary Committee,
dodged the question entirely
when shown the post
by a correspondent for NBC.
Chairman Jordan told him,
in the correspondent's words,
he can't read well without his glasses.
Well, the former president
apparently can though, especially,
it seems the tea leaves
because the Manhattan case
is only one of many.
And they all seem to be coming to a head,
especially this week.
The federal documents investigate
with his defense attorney,
Evan Corcoran, back
before a federal grand jury today
without attorney client privilege
to shield him
from potentially damaging questions.
There's that and now a ruling
that all of these former close aides
cannot use executive privilege
to avoid testimony
before the January 6th grand jury.
Put it all together
and there's plenty to keep anyone
up at night and tomorrow.
The former president has a campaign
rally in Waco, Texas.
As we approach
the 30th anniversary of this,
the FBI
raid on the Branch Davidian compound,
a time and place, an incident
that has become a touchstone for violent
anti-government groups and individuals.
And though
the Trump campaign says
it is a coincidence
The Houston Chronicle today
called the choice of location,
not just a dog whistle, but a, quote,
blaring air horn of a Mach 18 wheeler,
end quote, to extremists
Joining us now,
someone who saw a Trump incited mob up
close on January
six, former
Republican congressman
and senior political commentator for CNN
Adam Kinzinger.
Also CNN senior law enforcement
analyst and former deputy
FBI director Andrew McCabe,
and CNN chief
correspondent Kaitlan Collins.
Let me start with you.
How are the former president's
death and destruction comments
being viewed inside the Trump camp?
Because just days ago, his allies
and advisers
were privately urging him
to tone down the rhetoric.
Yeah,
they obviously didn't even
want him to call for protest,
really in this situation.
You saw
people like Speaker Kevin
McCarthy later
saying that Trump wasn't
calling for enhanced,
even though he very explicitly did so
on his own website through social.
And so this is definitely an escalation,
saying that there could
potentially be death or destruction
if he is indicted,
as we know
is pretty widely expected at this point,
even though it's
the timing of that, it's unclear.
And so
this is certainly a cause for concern.
I mean, it's been over a week
now that I've been hearing from
his allies
who were saying
they did not want to see anything
that anywhere close
resembled a January
six playing out
on the streets of Manhattan
because it was a major concern of theirs,
given how damaging it's been
for the former president.
And so this just shows, though,
I think that also his post
almost a week ago
now when he said
he was going to be arrested on Tuesday,
which obviously was not borne out
and there was no indication
that that was actually ever
anything
that was conveyed to his campaign
or to his to his world.
That just shows that he is
he is allowing it to build.
He is calling for protests.
He's even kind of mocking Republicans
who are saying that protest
should be peaceful.
He's saying they're
trying to destroy our country
and people are calling for these
peaceful protests in the wake of that.
So, Andrew,
how much does this inflammatory rhetoric
heighten the tension
and security concerns
of what may be a possible indictment
next week?
Well, it should
absolutely have heightened
the security concerns of professionals
who are involved in protecting
not just New York City,
but also Washington, D.C.
and any place else around this country
where extremist
supporters of the former
president might gather.
I mean, look, what we're seeing here is
is predictable
and it shouldn't surprise anyone.
He is a one note orchestra.
He, Donald Trump, appeals to the lowest
common denominator,
the most baser
violent instincts
of his most extreme supporters.
He's he did it on January 6th.
He summoned that mob to D.C.
to try to
obstruct the peaceful transfer of power.
And he's doing it now
to try to get himself out of trouble.
And to be clear,
he is in a lot of trouble.
We all watched this morning
while his attorney
in the documents
investigation
entered the grand jury
to testify against him.
I mean, that is an unprecedented thing
that we're seeing
And Evan
Corcoran is in a position to provide
unbelievably damaging
testimony against him.
Presumably that happened today.
And now eight of his of his closest
advisers have been told
they cannot rely on executive privilege
and things appear as well.
So it's a very, very bad week for Trump.
And predictably,
he goes low and is resorting
to the one thing that he does
better than anyone,
and that's appealing to people,
to violent tendencies.
You know, Congressman Kinzinger,
knowing everything you know
about the lead up to January six,
he wore on the January six committee.
How concerning
are these comments to you
and what does it say
that, you know,
Chairman Jim Jordan and Speaker
McCarthy aren't even addressing it?
So I'm
concerned not necessarily
about what happens in the next week
or two weeks.
It's all this stuff
radicalizes people over time.
And people may continue
to grow more thinking about violence
and eventually going to violence.
And it takes a spark that so far
we still think, you know, Trump
it never said like,
hey, come and use violence on my behalf,
but easily could.
And he's putting in people's minds
to use violence.
I got to tell you, John,
the thing that bothers me
the most
we could talk about this
whole it's the silence,
the silence of my colleagues,
my former colleagues.
You know,
every Republican
who holds elected office
has got to speak up.
I don't even care if you know,
you don't have to do it on national TV.
Put out a statement
that says there is the whole purpose, by
the way, of politics
is to prevent violence.
That's what politics was created.
The utter silence is so weak by my party
that I just.
To me, that's what I can't believe.
Even more than what Donald
Trump puts out on social.